it is friday time for what's trending
and las vegas now host mercedes martinez
joins us
live from the mix 94.1 studio mercedes
good morning so we're talking about
taylor swift and
bridgerton today yeah
some good stuff first up taylor swift
the deluxe version of her latest album
evermore
it was released yesterday and it's
complete with two
new bonus tracks they're called right
where you left me
and it's time to go which is causing
quite the stir because swifties think
she's singing about her former manager
scooter braun and her former label
big red machine
15 years 15 million tears
[Music]
praying to his greed
[Music]
ah those are some fighting words there
all of swift's music
was sold to scooter braun and then he
turned around and sold it
for 300 million dollars so she does not
own her first six album and this has
caused a huge beef
between the past between the two of them
for the past year
also trending this morning bridger 10
bridgerton's heartthrob
could be the next james bond the duke of
hastings
fans are campaigning to get rejean page
cast in the next movie after daniel
craig
exits the role he seemed to hint that it
could be possible
when he posted this little video last
month with the caption
regency royalty shaken and stirred
i guess we're gonna have to just wait
and see alex oh
uh we are all about that i he is a
fantastic actor on top of all that too
so have you been watching bridgerton
mercedes it's really good
i i just finished it last night and
i'm gonna go back and watch it again i
absolutely loved
did too it was really good all right uh
really quick we have to talk about this
too we keep talking about everything
from the 90s coming back
and now it's an iconic cake
yeah i feel like i'm always telling you
about something from the 90s coming back
and this one is
vianetta ice cream cake do you remember
this stuff
check out the old school commercial that
we found for it now good
humor announced this week that they are
reviving
the dessert they said it's only going to
be available in vanilla for now
but the ice cream it's it's served up
between these crispy decadent chocolate
layers
in a unique cake shape and they say that
you can just slice it and there's a
piece for the whole family
i uh i remember as a kid thinking this
was the fanciest dessert to ever
exist it was pretty amazing uh you know
i don't remember having this stuff
it just reminds me of lasagna and you
take a big knife
and giving everyone a slice of lasagna
so
dessert lasagna i love it let's mark it
that way that's perfect
uh good stuff mercedes it's great to see
you hope you had great holidays
and uh we'll see you next week have a
great weekend see you later happy new
year bye thank